let us not
i beseech you deceive ourselves
we have done everything that could be
done to avert the storm which is now
coming on
we have petitioned
we have remonstrated we have supplicated
we have prostrated ourselves before the
throne and have implored it into
position to arrest the tyrannical hands
of the ministry
and parliament
but our petitions have been slighted
our remonstrances have produced
additional violence and insult
our supplications have been disregarded
and we have been spurned with contempt
from the foot of the throne
in vain
after these things
may we indulge in fond hope
of peace
and reconciliation
there is no longer any room for hope
if we wish to be free we must fight
i repeat it sir we must fight
and appeal to arms and to the god of
hosts is all that has left us
they
tell us that we are weak
unable to cope with so
formidable an adversary
but when shall we be stronger
will it be the next week or the next
year
will it be when we are totally disarmed
and when a british guard shall be
stationed in every house
shall we gather strength by irresolution
and inaction
shall we acquire the means
of effectual resistance by
lying supinely on our backs and hugging
the delusive phantom of hope until our
enemies shall have us bound
hand and foot
sir
we are not weak if we make a proper use
of those means which the god of nature
hath placed in our power
the millions of people
armed
in the holy cause of liberty
and in such a country as that which we
possess
are invincible
by any force which our enemy can send
against us
besides sir
we shall not fight our battles alone
there is a just god who presides over
the destinies of nations and who will
raise up friends to fight our battles
with us
the battle sir is not to the strong
alone
it is to the vigilant the active
the brave
there is no retreat
but in submission
and slavery
our chains are forged
the war is inevitable and let it come
i repeat it sir let it come
it is in vain sir to extenuate the
matter
gentlemen may cry peace peace but there
is no peace
the war has actually begun
the next gale that sweeps from the north
will bring to our ears the clash of
resounding arms
our brethren
are already in the field
why stand we here idle
what is it that we gentlemen wish
what would they have
is life
so dear or peace so sweet as to be
purchased at the price of chains and
slavery
forbid it almighty god
i know not what course others may take
but as for me
give me liberty
or give me death